foreign  [Music]  's about revenge  can't help but think users too  [Music]  I've lived here my whole life  I've seen Hell in a main Hill  so long sergeant  do you remember  there you've been one of us but out here  you're one of them  not to fight don't pick it  was like magic  only this afternoon you were tied up  there I was lying down over there both  about to get killed and yet here we are  and it's everyone else that's dead  someone killed my child  [Music]  you help me  can you shoot I have to  oh you'll laugh dude  of course the woman I expected  you're everything I'd expect of a man  [Laughter]  something about this country  I sometimes wonder if there's Horror in  USA  [Music]